[Music]  we're not be a Guana  I say those - yes can you know either me  simply you're not ba hey yes  the own let's go we're running late  better solar beam APIs are easier see  Juana's cincuenta daniela Ramos  [Music]  that is not your progress come with me  or you're dead minutes thirty seconds  I am I'm not gonna get my kid in my back  that's it buster why are you Kenny  you're my mission  [Music]  where's that my name is Sarah Connor I  hunt terminators enough of a resume for  you  how do we stop this thing  I'm going to help you change the future  I'm done running I'm gonna spend and  fight  you can't die  if you don't make it  everybody dies why not just let me have  it  because we're not machines metal mother  [Music]  [Music]